I'm sorry, but, uh, I,
wasn't going to say I was going to say something about the, Oh, you know what?
I laughed so hard at, in, in, uh, in, it was a pretty scammy, six were the,
one of the biggest, many big, bad guy, big bags.
And we're trying to remake that movie actually like a couple of years ago.
I also got you a box set of DVDs and you definitely never opened them from my
brother. Oh yeah. I remember you got me down. You didn't open up,
but that was you pull riser by me. so, um, so,
uh, so he, uh, so, and then the big bad guy, uh,
ha stole ice cream and then he went to go eat it and it fell on the,
on the concrete. And he says, Oh crap, Hola.
And I thought that guy, that the juxtaposition of him, Oh,
this is, is this the scene? Oh my God, this is it. Let me play it.
Let me play it. What is it? You just literally Googled crappola no man.
Police Academy, six ice cream. Oh really? But it's called crappola. Oh,
it is. Yeah. Crap. Hold on, hold on. Oh my God. Here.
It's so we thought everything's online. I know. Always was.
That's so funny when I was eight. Look,
look is that Laravel no, push it back a little bit, boy. Never. We go,
Oh crap. Hold up. Oh yeah. I forgot about that. Oh,
you know what the, what the done that.
You know, what's so bad about the scene.
This is I'm going to I'm already to disagree. No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's good to be ready to agree or disagree. I agree with that. Okay.
But this is a mistake. This is not the script. Okay.
This is a mistake that happened during shooting and they should have just done
it again. All right. What is it? I don't know if I agree, dude,
the actors saw S a bad that he goes to eat it and then it
kind of falls off, but he knows it's supposed to fall. She's it off. And then,
and then he waits for it, but he reacts too soon. Watch.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy, look, look, watch, watch it.
Also just cut earlier when it starts to tip, you know? Yeah.
So with one arm, just do it again. Just do it again.
Also tell you what I do like about that sequence though.
The close-up of the ice cream falling is, is rad.
Like that makes it to me way better, so much. So that while it was happening,
I was like great closeup. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. I love to maker.
I'm a filmmaker. When I say, I don't know. That's what you say.
That one of my favorite things about this is going to look at the YouTube
comments is always so funny. Can't believe I've found this. Whoever put this up.
Thank you. It's still okay. I remember this. Oh,
it was that guy, but that, that actor is rad and in so much. Oh,
let me see. Tall guy. Really? Yeah. Yeah. Hmm.
That's funny that there's other people's favorite parts. This is the internet.
Here's the thing, though. There is no scene that you can't find.
If it's from a movie, you remember you had other people remember it too.
And it's online, dude. Hold on a second though. Uh, what?
I was going to say something about this. Yeah. That's so bad. You're right,
dude.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy. So much.
Oh, try Paula. By the way.
He's saying, Oh boy. So much, because honestly he's such a bad.
Right? Right, right, right. Like no reaction here is it? Matter of fact.
Don't watch this. Just listen.
It couldn't sound more like a guy bust a nut too quick.
Right, right, right. Yeah. Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
And then the crap older. Just listened to it. Don't my eyes.
okay. I I'm ready. Listen.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
And that's him coming? Oh crap. Hold on.
And he came too early. The old crap all day. She came to the,
Oh boy. Oh boy is a really, I'm going to come to quickly.
It is in the laughing too, because he's so nervous. He's so nervous.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Oh boy.
Oh, the amount he's out of breath. Like that's exactly aligned.
With it's because he's so big and walking.
Right, right. Right. If you're that big,
just walking gets you straight up out of. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We all know that.
We all know that. So for sure. Um, okay. Wait,
so man. I'm laughing. You know,
I know I'm laughing. I laughed so much, dude. Do you laugh a lot?
Some people don't love it. So I talk about this one dozen buckets.
I just don't get some people just don't laugh, dude,
laugh more like everybody laugh more. Now people don't want to,
they want to be so serious. And so, so taken so seriously. That's so upsetting.
I know, but whatever crappola, you know, total crappola.
Um, I wanna thing. So I know that's in your mind. Yeah.
That's what's fitting the guy from police Academy. So no, that guy was around.
Yeah. Yeah. By the way,
let's just say right now there was no one greater in the eighties or nineties
then whoever that guy was,
who did all the sounds in police Academy and that's it.
And we're not talking about it. Yeah. I mean,
PR police got to miss so much great. The dude, Paul Proctor. I mean that, dude,
I just made fun of this last night on stage.
I just talked about this last night on stage, the, the, the,
the, the,
the mic was buzzing when I was on stage and it wouldn't stop.
And I got the guy, I was like, yo, can you fix this?
And they had to literally bring a ladder on stage to go up while I'm on stage
to go up and unplug a speaker.
So it would stop buzzing. And when he got on the ladder,
it kind of like fell back a little bit. And I was like, Oh, I John candy movie.
Like, like, I was like, I was like, like you remember in the eighties,
when they would like do and they wouldn't stop themselves, they'd be like, Whoa.
And he'd keep holding on the, you like, just let go.
And then I brought up like the where he'd be like, Oh,
I have to tell you something. And he'd be like, Proctor, not now, you know?
And he'd be like, but I have to.
And then you get hit in the head with an anvil and just say the thing,
just be like, does it Advil? I just said that on LA.
On stage last night. Yeah. Those police Academy movies are the.
Michael Winslow was the guy, but yeah, Michael wins though.
And he was the Vel.
Michael Winslow was the guy that would just go like nobody's character was yeah.
The Lavelle Lavelle Jones. Yeah. Michael Winslow is the guy's rules.
Um, so eh, by the way, you know,
a white guy wrote the script and named the character. Laravel and that's racist.
So, um, Laravel Carvel. Yeah. I guess. Or like larva.
Okay. And then, but then remember the David Graf, go back, go back.
You're going too far. One fire. And so too far, he's going too far. Right?
He went too far. That makes us mad. He's just going way too far, too fast.
So David graph,
Eugene Tackleberry remember when he held the gun to the shark and the shark swim
away.
Tackleberry and high tower where like the bad-ass wall and then Steve Gutenberg.
Do it. Let me just say this right. I'm going to agree, dude.
Steve Gutenberg's face. Yeah, dude. Okay.
I'm I was so ready to agree. I don't know where you're going to say. Yeah,
I agree. No,
Steve Gutenberg's face Steve Gutenberg.
His face looks like Steve.
It looks like he's wearing a Steve Gutenberg face.
Dude. Look how rad look at that.
Oh dude. Steve Gutenberg.
The picture that you have with the purple that's so suicide behind it.
Dude, that guy, the devil and Steve Gutenberg. That is an article I'd read.
I'd prioritize, reading that article over almost anything. You know,
Steve Gutenberg gets so mad. He blacked out for 20 minutes.
It wakes up and thinks, Oh God, let's what were we doing?
You know what else though? To what? For real, his,
his Dick hard is like three inches, you know? Yeah.
No, his Dick is bigger limp than it is hard.
It goes bans a little bit. Like scientists would look at it and they'd be like,
what's going on? Yeah. They could be like, first of all,
take off that mask and be like, not a mask, but Steve Gutenberg.
How much is Steve Goldberg? A guy that would get into jujitsu later.
Wow, dude,
you join a jujitsu class and you'd be like, Oh my gosh,
did you have a Bloomberg? And he here's a Brown.
Belt while he's going through a divorce while he's going through.
A divorce. You're like heard it's good for your mom.
He is so a guy that would get into jujitsu late in life.
How many Holy of him are.
There with his shirt off. And why is he so yoked dude?
Looking at it. There's a video on YouTube. Steve Gutenberg, shirtless.
He's got the raddest body. That's something ever already.
I knew that already. Every time he took off his shirt,
he was so shredded and also puffed.
It was unbelievable how shredded it was because his face doesn't go with a
shredded body doesn't but it does in the eighties. And that's why,
that's why he was so famous because they keep [inaudible] eighties. I mean,
he was great, man. What a rad guy does he ever know?
Smile? I don't think so. Like when he's sleeping he's he's got his teeth,
right? I think it rad body. I think so. Oh.
Does it Google do jujitsu and Steve Goldberg might get lucky go to
Google images. He wasn't three men and a baby, which also rules. Yep.
He did a lot of cool. Talk about a guy that just couldn't be famous.
Now if he was that age now,
like he would literally never get hired. Yeah.
I know like much of like a regular looking white guy. Like yeah.
Good luck, dude. I'm still laughing at you.
Who the is that guy? Yeah. John Heinz. Owner of him. Monkey bar gym. Um, dude,
uh, no Steve Gutenberg for sure. I can't. I mean,
cause I used to do jujitsu.
There would be guys that would be like in the class and he would just so be one
of those guys and he would be good and it'd be so annoying and you'd be like,
Hey, I should be able to kick his, but right.
He's also got really good chest hair. That guy. Yeah, he does.
He's also aged kind of well, he looks kind of good.
He just looks exactly the same. Ah, man. What's he doing?
There's go him and polarize. You need to do a movie dude about jujitsu. Yeah.
They could play like brothers of all time. That would be the worst.
A movie of all time. If Steve Gutenberg and what's his name? Andy Paul riser.
Dead movie about jujitsu at late in life. I mean I would,
but the thing is it would be bad,
but there's no way I wouldn't watch the living out of it. Look,
he was a short circuit. Could cause so much. Look at that.
There's nothing more eighties than go down.
Then that image right there of that thing, go down.
Look the classic trailer of the two people yelling with loud dude to Laravel,
you know, Vail a bro, for no reason, it will be like,
well we gotta get Le Laravel on the case. And then he would just be like, blah,
blah. Yeah. And then they break in the thing. Nobody would do the air.
He'd walked through the airport thing and he would do the sound for no reason.
No reason. Even as a kid, I was like, dude,
did he get the part or did they write the thing? The perfect guy.
Let me tell you something.
I have thought about that exact question. Yeah.
For like a grand total, probably of like 70 hours.
We can find that out. It's very easy to find that out.
We just find out one of the writers and and but, but they,
they had to written it for like, you know, you know what I mean? Like,
well maybe he got the part and they were like, no, no, no there's no day.
Like I know what the ride was. Like.
I also know this guy who could do sound effects.
We could include that into the thing. Right.
Maybe he was already big for being that, got to get the sound guy.
He was probably like a comedian ish kind of guy that would do like,
sounds like an impression of comedians and.